[Music]
can I confess something I was really
very scared to beat you me yes
gorgeous and talented in your connection
with David yeah there was a time when I
thought we were on the road to getting
back together and he met you Sarah Julia
hi Julia
bye Lily say bye to mommy my spear y'all
get used to Tessa she's adjusting to
nose-down Peeta I know she's Lilly's
mother and of course I respect that
but it feels like I'm stepping into her
life it's not easy all this change you
get it now you don't you couldn't
possibly
don't worry in no time
you won't be back with mommy how well do
you really know to you you are a
survivor and what happened was not your
fault I only had David and Lily you took
everything away from me who's that your
flowers what do you mean there's no
record or consent the arrangement take a
deep breath no one knows where you live
where's your ring how come you into the
Lana she's messing with me I made one
mistake
there isn't a nika's pilot Tessa July
you're worthless Julia you always be
worthless Tessa why are you here
[Music]
David you should never have brought her
here
done with crazy David right in front of
me she sends me this face the man is
dead found in your home look you see
what this looks like right so choose one
behind all of this
enough is enough are you threatening me
yes I'm threatening you
this is my life it's my what's ad
nauseum you don't know well looks like
someone needs school who can tell